ciao ragazzi bentornato in una puntata
di cucina buttata sono io ho vestito da
casa tendenzialmente anche se continuo a
pensare di avere un grande stile oggi
faremo una ricetta facilissima e veloce
ma soprattutto iconica perché stiamo
parlando del whopper di burger king lo
conoscono tutti quanti è oggi un pochino
come ho fatto con la serie di mcdonald's
cercheremo di riprodurre questo
hamburger di questa catena di fast food
a fine abbiamo preso uno vero ti giuro
che non ci siamo mangiati 4 io e
gianmarco è motivo per cui abbiamo preso
perché vogliamo paragonarlo proprio in
maniera oggettiva a quello che andremo a
creare abbiamo trovato la ricetta è
molto più semplice degli altri panini
mcdonald che in realtà hanno gli
ingredienti un pochino più misteriosi
segreti se volete recuperarli tra
parentesi avete la possibilità di
cliccare in giro nell'info box abbiamo
fatto il crispi che suscitano anche da
dio dio la salsa era praticamente
identiche abbia fatto il big match
abbiamo fatto un poletti è reato il
momento però di abbandonare un secondo
mcdonald's e buttarci su burger king per
fare il bomber del burger king avremmo
bisogno di un panino e semi già fatto da
qualcun altro nel tritato ho fatto già
da un manzo cetriolini e grandi quanto
il pene di enrico pomodori cipolla
tipico odore dell'alito di enrico
lattuga quella che io non maionese e che
per prima cosa io andrei a scartare il
nostro whopper in modo anche da
analizzare cosa andiamo a incontrare nel
momento in cui la garde gianmarco fatto
un lavoro pazze è leggermente più
piccolo è pazzesco ottimo ottimo lavoro
gianmarco sono già impressionato
clicchiamo qui sotto un plauso mangiando
clausa gianmarco possiamo scrivere qua
sotto gianmarco best l'alto scrivetelo
altrimenti poi non mi mandate se siete
spiegati non siamo disposti a fare una
cosa stupida come scrivere gianmarco
benz plauso come potremmo fare un
qualcosa di più importante nella nostra
vita che ci chiederà magari più sforzo
quindi adesso tu tu che stai guardando
tu ti iscrivi attivi quella campanella
sbaglia è proprio il simbolo di una
campanella e se non le conoscenze in
maniera campanella corte che nel suo
tema citofonato in vita tua forse una
persona sola e a maggior ragione se una
persona sola youtube è il tuo unico
amico metti pure un pollice in su
altrimenti sai che faccio niente
liberissimo di non farlo pure abbastanza
semplice come panino posso dire o due
ingredienti per pozzi secondo nera che
il nostro uomo per sarà più buono di
questo addirittura ragazzi sono tutti
ingredienti freschi e con l'uso
differenze me forse saremo un pochino
più generosi del tizio che ci ha messo
tutta ci vuole da una parte
andiamo a pesare intanto il tritato 116
hype lavoriamo bene in modo da unire
tutto quanto avete presente che il
territorio inizialmente viene fatto
quasi a cervello lo sto spappolando in
modo da eliminare l'aria all'interno e
poter fare un hamburger perfetto e
compatto epico come dirgli molliamo
scilla grande creatore di hamburger a
mani nude
mi viene da dire proprio non far ridere
pure tu ridi rete delle sue battute di
merda aggiungo prendo un piatto un
saluto agli amici 23 bassi ragazze io
amo questi piatti sono impazzito per
loro perché sono chiatti duri come il
mio cranio cerchiamo di fare un taglio
seguendo il naturale bordo se proprio
bisogna sbagliare è meglio sbagliare
verso l'alto io non sbaglio mai vediamo
pero se gli danno una leggera bruscata
non sopra ma solo dentro facendo il
fuoco che inizia a dare una leggerissima
bruscata all'interno del panino ti piace
coltello vado a fare le nostre fette 12
loro ne mettono veramente poker e cerco
di mantenere intatto il succo dentro la
fetta evito che perda questo liquido
proseguo ragazzi la cipolla lì ce n'è
veramente messi male e poca devo esser
sincero anche qui cercherò di essere un
minimo più generoso bagnato non so cosa
ti riferisci
abbiamo controllato il pane perché in
due secondi si brucia andrà poi a
scegliere bene gli anelli con i quali
con dirlo sicuramente la parte interna
la tolgo a questa di mina che
teoricamente non è presente all'interno
di panini che noi abbiamo appena visto
cosa lascia trapolino ma se stanno
facendo
prendo i celerini ragazzi loro usano
centri nodi più grossi
noi quindi noi dovremo utilizzare un
pochino di più di questi piccoli
io so che esistono da fuori persone che
non amano il sapore dei cetriolini e non
so che problemi abbiate poiché non
mangiare i cetriolini io li trovo la
cosa più buono al mondo sapete che non
amo i terreni ringraziano
ora che il cari non prendo intanto un
hamburger e con meno delicatezza lo
butto sulla piastra mi raccomando per
una buona cottura di un hamburger dovete
lasciarlo stare sulla piastra adesso
sembra sia staccarlo se fa volerebbe un
minimo va cotta la carne se decide di
cuocerla faremo meglio ben cotto perché
di base gli hamburger che vengono fatti
dei fast food sono made ben cotte a
questa lattuga che è perfetta gianmarco
preso ingredienti perfetti gianmarco the
best plauso nei commenti è un like like
che in italiano si traduce il plauso
lasciatesi un bel plauso l'insuperato
rozzo nel taglio della lattuga
in realtà vorrei prendere quella più
carina 12 all'insalata trattiene molta
acqua
prendetela asciugatela perché già il
promotore bagnato ci metterete le salse
rischio rientare un con il liquido
proprio imbarazzante
invece così fu un minimo dovrebbe
salvare la situazione creando e giro
sembra che io sappia ciò che faccio sera
è invece so esattamente dove mi sto
muovendo altra cosa all'interno
dell'hamburger lo inseriscono ketchup e
maionese ma non li mischiano con i
propri e basta al mcdonald's i panini
vengono montati al contrario che faccio
vedere prendo la parte superiore e
ketchup maionese insalata e la butto
direttamente ad incollarsi vedete contro
la salsa cipolla 12 ad anelli più
stretti a riempirsi
croce trio dini pomodoro leggera salata
l'hamburger e lo sposto chiudo
e a questo punto rigiro signori il web
per fatto in fretta e furia facciamo un
paragone
il nostro è più alto abbiamo una
presenza di ingredienti più consistente
la nostra il senato si vede tutto quanto
poi vi piace più quello di test era
chiaramente quella destra che ha
espresso espresso e vero quale sarà il
più buono già marco bui euro vorrei
innanzitutto farti assaggiare
l'originale è come se non ce lo fossimo
già sfonda le demo sfornati di water a
testa e allora che non ricordavo
romangia volante un buono un semplice
genuino però mi viene da dire c'è un
qualcosa oltre gli ingredienti affermati
da burger king che sfugge che è quel
segreto che c'ha ogni catena non esiste
l'ingrediente segreto è ingrediente
segreto sei tu
mamma mia che per ecco la seconda occhio
più a magnano bullismo allora non
c'entra niente
1 non ritrovo un singolo sapori di quel
panino
com'è possibile che utilizzando però gli
stessi ingredienti perché secondo voi
due panini infatti nello stesso modo
vanno due sapori tendenzialmente diverse
io se posso dirvi la mia non mi fermerò
andrò a fondo e capirò pil che pure che
in giacimenti cimenti perché il pan il
burger che è così diverso laddove il
nostro crispin bacon lasciamo mi ricordo
qua sotto
era praticamente identico pasto della
lamaro imboccare anche un paio di
cetriolini perché vi diamo appuntamento
al prossimo video giovedi alle 14 ciao